a gospel Vegas and he'll talk about llms
as linguists thank you so much thanks
for the afternoon
so I want to talk today about the
meta-linguistic ability of LOLs and all
the papers I'm going to talk about are
uploaded here so what we've learned I
think so far is that oh I'm scheduled
language pretty well
um I think that's that's now relatively
accepted
um so you can ask it to write a poem and
about a workshop on that alums at UC
Berkeley and it does that you can ask it
to try to understand this sentence the
amount of the cat that the dog painted
thought sang uh who did what
hahaha
okay uh GPT has no problem with that so
so the cat pain the dark painted the cat
the cat thought The Mouse and the mouse
thanks so this is Senator bedding so
they can they can understand this
um pretty well
um as cognitive models so as models of
human language learning I don't think
those Transformers are the best models
uh why no baby learns from text
um and pies of texts or no babies learn
from so much tax as GPT 4 is trained on
um no baby learns without the production
perception Loop right the way we learn
language is we speak and we listen
um so instead of text we use speech in
the first five years
um seven years however when it depends
on when you start reading
um and no baby learns without
communicative intent so in fact when I
try to do language modeling I I I I
prefer Gans now this talk is not about
Gans because this is a Transformer
workshop and I don't want to talk about
dance because I'll be biased because I
prefer games for cognitive modeling they
learn more like humans from continuous
speech data they get symbolic
representations on the way uh that
resembles resembles how humans learn
language uh you can build models where
they you know there's a perception
production Loop the really interesting
part about gen is that they learn by
imitation imagination they have
communicative intent and so on so as a
model of cognitive cognitive language
development I don't think llms are are
amazing I mean you can do stuff with
them as well another Advantage by the
way of speech is speech is more
interpretable in many ways than text so
you can do kind of this introspection
interpretability that I'm gonna talk
about a little bit about later
um so so I I'm not particularly
fascinated by llms in terms of you know
being a realistic human-like model of
language learning I am fascinated by
them um in in terms of they can tell us
how what is possible in uh artificial
neurocomic computation right so
obviously language
um they can do language pretty well so
it's language abilities can emerge in an
artificial neural network that has no
language like neurons or whatever
devices
so they're great for telling us what is
possible in in a NS so if you think of
what the next Frontier is now that the
language is kind of you know we all
agree that LMS do language well what's
the next Frontier and the next you know
if you think of a child at five years
old they can speak pretty well their
language is pretty good but they won't
be able to tell you what a noun is or
what the verb is or whether the voice is
fricative is whatever glottal stop is
although they are using those
um so what what we wanted to test is can
these large language models reason about
language itself and you know this is
kind of a testing metacognitive
abilities of llms and probably the the
easiest metacognitive ability that the
llm can do is meta-linguistics why
because they're trained essentially on
language right the training data is
language so we can't we have to ask
ourselves can they analyze language
itself
um and why is this question important
basically it tells us that we can test
the network for the next level of
ability right so cognitively
meta-linguistics is comes later in
development is more complex
and also I'm gonna try to show the
linguistic formalism so you know formal
linguistic theory that was developed by
um you know charmsky and people before
him is a really good tool to do this
kind of behavior interpretability of
these models now that we cannot really
do introspective Behavior
interpretability anymore or not as as
easily so you can ask yourself you know
does gpd4 has access or learns
linguistic structure by asking the model
itself how much of that you have right
so this is kind of a linguistic theory
formalism is a really nice tool to
introspect the model's behaviorally what
I call behavioral interpretability
so back in the day I mean when models
were still small I guess we can still do
that but interpretability meant that you
can you know look inside the neurons and
say oh these neurons are doing that
another models are proprietary and huge
to the degree that it's really difficult
to do you know um a sophisticated
computation of them
um we might have this other tool which
is behavior interpretability where you
could just explicitly ask the model what
did you do or how did you get to this
answer and meta linguistic aspect is one
of the easiest for um to do that the
easiest way to do that
um so far the models were not good on
meta-linguistics right gpt3 bar and
other models not really good not giving
consistent answer not
not they're they didn't they weren't
able to analyze language itself
um and we argue that gpd4 might be the
first model that can cons inherently
give
um meta-linguistic analysis basically
they can act as linguists and use
linguistic Theory linguistic formalism
to analyze sentences so how does this
look like so not only you can ask the
model
um you know who did what in the sentence
the mouse that the cat that the dark
painted thought saying it can also also
tell them you know use chomsky's
syntactic formalism and analyze this
sentence and it you know spells out a
nice latex version of uh of of what
linguists would do
um with you know triple Center or
betting sentence uh with a really really
good approximation to hold a linguist
would analyze this sentence
so um there's all sorts of things that
you can test with it I mean syntax syn
technicians for decades have been coming
with this really cool examples to see
how much of structure do like the people
have right and one of the most famous
example is you know I saw an elephant
but binoculars that sense has the
reading the elephant can have binoculars
or your side with the monoculars right
and
if you ask gpt3
uh does you know analyze this sentence
it just gives you a the same structure
for both sentences now gpt4 gives you a
nice distinction between first sentence
where the binoculars are modifying uh
the the
um the verb
um and the second sentence where
binoculars are modifying the elephant
right I couldn't do this in a stable
diffusion I couldn't find a way to make
Stables the fusion draw elephant we
binoculars
um so maybe you say well you know it saw
a million of linguistic textbooks where
this sentence was prominently discussed
and that's available to projection but
there's a way we can work around that
um so you can come up with other
sentences that are less prevalent in
linguistic textbooks so I've had my baby
turtles this is getting into a little
inappropriate territory
um and that Center still has two
readings right you have small baby young
Turtles and you feed them or you have a
baby and you feed the turtles
um gpt4 nicely and gets both readings
and analyze it as a linguist would I was
trying real hard to do this in stable
diffusion he said how do I make a
picture of a baby or somebody feeding
baby turtles feeding the human baby
turtles and I was having trouble and
then maybe I should change the style and
then okay
what painter
would allowed such a thing and be
obviously obvious answer is here on Imus
Bosch and if you actually say you know I
fed the baby turtle in the style of
Hieronymus Bosch it's the only way I
could get a picture and this is not even
the most bad one they're like worst
pictures so um stable diffusion I
apparently was able to do it only with
the here on Miss Bosh Style
not only you can do that in English
which is you know probably probably in
the training I mean it's possible that
the models have a lot of labeled data
syntactic data in the training so you
can do other languages and there's all
sorts of things you can do um you know
you can have a German sentence
say that he ate yesterday
um and you know it produces trees
um that would look good to linguists
that reveal that you know it really has
a good representation of the structure
behind this this sense and and you know
they're really fine-grained details that
you can force the model to check so it
can have traces it can have all sorts of
um linguistic theoretical linguistic
approaches that that um you know we have
learned throughout the history so you
might say well this is all um memorized
and you know just um not not too uh too
big of a deal if if they can generalize
from this luckily we have phonology will
not go into that but there you can
really make up toy languages that the
network for sure didn't have when
because you've just made it up and um
I'm sure you you're not too interested
in a lot logical Theory but it can give
you really valid explanation of really
complex you know graduate level
phonological theory for example
optimality Theory and so on
I can also do semantic analysis so
basically my point is that we can use
linguistic formalism to really test all
sorts of things that we've been testing
and what we've done in in this paper is
just a few of them and again one thing
that I maybe another test case that I
that I can give you that is really
interesting
um one thing that we believe that only
human language has is a recursion right
so a process where you take a
constituent and embed it in a in another
uh constituent of the same type
infinitely right so it's definitely
Infinity of language so for example you
can always say Mary said that John said
that whales have language and then you
can always embed that into a higher
level uh sentence uh David said that
Mary said that John said that whales
have language and uh so this humans have
this animals probably not so now we can
test can artificial neural network you
know that Candela ability emerge and you
know you can give it a bunch of
sentences ask them is this uh is this a
recursive sentence or not and it
correctly identifies them and they say
Okay add recursion to these sentences
and it gives you this nice example for
example a cat bit Martha's dog's tail
and it adds two more layers a cat bit
Marta's neighbor's sister's dog's tail
and so and it can go really really long
we also tested it on visual recursion so
how we can deal with visual recursion
and apparently
um you know it it draws this really
really nice pictures with with kind of
recursive structure so what we can learn
from this is that uh you know an ability
to do explicit recursion that we thought
is only possible in humans can emerge in
these large language months I'm not
saying that there that there are you
know cognitive possible model but we can
test what is possible and we can kind of
have linguistic Theory as this as this
window into their internal
representation now that introspection is
much more difficult because the models
are huge there of course pitfalls that
we discussed in the papers uh we don't
know whether model architecture
obviously is precisely
um we don't know what the training data
was but I mentioned those are not
unsurmountable tasks we can use
phonology you can make up language
memorization obviously is a problem in
replicability and so just to conclude
because we're running out of time and
I'll have some time for questions
um so the idea is for the first time
llms can do
meta-linguistics so metacognitive
abilities and there's they can be a
window into their you know internal
structure and and how they use that
um and so llms are pretty good linguists
um I asked a colleague how how would you
rate this output and they say well b b
plus B minus some something along those
lines if a graduate student did it
um and so uh yeah this is this is this
is they're good linguists what remains
to be seen if if they can
provide novel analysis right if if they
can give us new insights they can do
pretty well on what is available to them
right now well remains to be seen as
they if they can be um Innovative okay
let's um uh take homes and the QR code
where papers are available I think we
have some questions some time for
questions uh we can take a short
question and maybe the other uh the next
speaker can come set up thank you
um
examples
Behavior
Oh you mean oh well
um we haven't tested that yeah I would
be interesting to see but the question
the other question is how well does the
language represented so you know there
are differences in training data
all right
thank you so much thank you for the nice
talk
[Applause]
foreign
empirical law of data separation in
neural networks
thank you and it's my greatest pressure
to Turbo something uh about my work on
deep learning uh I will try to make as
much as possible the connection to a
large language model so there's a joint
work with my former student Han funker
who has started to be a system professor
at the University of broadcast
so this is very simple and the two small
adverse tiny experiments training and
it's there feed forward new network on
fashionists with 10 different classes
so here each point denotes a a image so
we project the
uh the embedding for a well-trained
neural network from first layer second
layer last layer onto a two-dimensional
plan so each point is an image so you
see different colors denote different
class classes yes so there are 10
different classes so you see from the
first layer to the last layer and the
images are gradually separated according
to their different classes
and so by the way so they just denote
either and and the phrase our training
the network has been sufficiently
trained
looks like they are separated but it's
hard it's not in a precise way that we
can describe very clearly so now let's
try to see a experiment uh in another
experiment same experiment but a
illustration here each point the y-axis
you know how well the data are separated
according to different classes and this
denotes the original data layer zero so
this is the data Apple which had passed
the first layer layer one and this is
layer eight okay and the one when you
ever see such things uh you require so
that we can fit a simple least Square
line the correlation is almost perfect
so this was a little bit surprise for us
when we uh in the process of doing
experiments
so so far at this moment I haven't told
you about what does y stand for roughly
y stand for how well did I separate it
it's a very well be large if the data
are not well separated according to
classes but it's more if they are well
separated by the precise definition will
be given very soon okay so so they are
the same experiments and under on this
part it's very rough
but um this part is very precise but
they are denoted the same same
experiment so this point corresponds to
this and this data and this corresponds
to data of of the process in the first
layer okay
uh okay so
so we have done more experiments and uh
with using different optimization
methods and with different number of
layers so such linear pattern occurs
consistently so it's like physics
physical law
and now unless uh formally introduce
what does the y-axis denote
and so it's a classification problem so
there are 10 K different classes and
this is the class mean and this means uh
means for example an average cat
and this is global mean and now we
denote two different two different
matrices the first Matrix denotes the
signal so basically this is the converse
Matrix of the of the class means okay
basically measures how how different a
an average cat
from an average average stock if they
are far away from each other then it's
uh it's good the The Matrix will be
large in terms of eigenvalues so this is
a noise so basically this it denotes the
within class variation how different a
typical cat from the average average cat
okay if this is large means that the cat
has not been
concentrated so finally we Define this
measure D okay so this is the trace of
the two matches so basically this is the
noise denoted by over signal so this is
basically the inverse signal to noise
ratio
essentially it's to project the within
class variation as noise onto the K
minus one column space spent by this K
different classes
okay and we have this measure and we
call this is a row uh we call it the law
of equity separation because this shows
that on the log scale of this d uh the
Improvement across the first layer to
last layer is basically equal it's
basically equal
so roughly speaking this DT the measure
looks like something happening in
physics like radiation say a constant
times a value between 0 and 1 to the
power of t t notes there how many layers
the data have have passed
okay here nonlinearities is crucial with
if the new number is linear linear in
your network we won't see such a thing
so we have done uh so how does this law
emerge at beginning this the measure can
increase at Epoch zero at the beginning
the weights are ID equals here for
example and then the measure can even
increase and after training for just for
a while then they will decrease and the
more your chain the the ending value of
the smaller the ending value will be but
you see from just 100 people to the the
pattern is quite straight quite linear
so so far uh it is lower Progressive we
have done many experiments on both the
vision classification tasks yes it's
pervasive but not Universal there are
some like some tasks where this row
doesn't appear
okay and there are some insights and an
intuition why this happens yes
uh can we prove this law not yet it's
very surprising because usually whenever
you see such linear pattern there must
be very strong very simple underlying
mechanism governing this linear Decay
but at this moment uh we cannot prove it
and that's really something I hope to
see from your comments
okay and so we have uh tests on
different data different balance level
different learning rates the linear
Decay is a consistent
and the different architectures for
convolutionary networks is still linear
a little bit further compared with CD4
neural networks
and now let's try
minutes more so uh we can let's talk
about architecture training
interpretation
from this uh from this row
and the first addition that's the
network really should be deep right but
this is not the whole story and the
VidCon plus there is other law with
different number of depths and for
simple simple data set the optimal depth
can be like five or six and for slightly
complex dealer the optimal depth can be
12. it depends on the depth so this is
essentially the slope actually is just a
lot of row you see that the logarow will
be larger uh well well yeah the row will
be become closer to one if you have a
larger depth
okay and so here uh as long as the width
is large enough then some saturation
phenomenon the law doesn't depend on too
much if we first increase the depth from
100 to 1000 it doesn't but if the depth
is really 20 like 20 neurons 10 neuron
is really small cannot pass the
sufficient information for
classification
I did
your your the metric you have in the
vertical axis that's for the training
data yeah
held out data does it also do that yeah
good question on the test regime the
lead indicates not that clear it's a
just roughly it's still decreasing but
it's not linear it's not the linear it's
differently for the even if the
performance is good even generalization
is good yeah
doesn't show the same yeah everything
cares about it training yeah it's a
training is in training so the Chinese
are is a it's a linear pattern it's very
strong but when we move to test the
linear we always say decreasing pattern
but not as linear
thank you
okay and uh some uh
intuition why this look could happen so
this is something like for example if we
perturb the neural network because
usually STD wants to find some local
minimum which is wide right so if we
perturb the way it suppose that each
fraction will deviate by Epsilon and
when does this overall product change
the the division will be minimized this
is where uh the other fractions are
equal to each other if we have the
product is fixed so this is a simple
geometric inequality so this shows that
if we for example we want to double the
gvt into 10 years we need to
increase the gbt every year by seven
percent not too much or not too low
every year so this sound rough intuition
but it's not that does not have to
approve
okay and this is also in price
presentation a good generalization if
this law occurs and the generalization
in general will be better than when it
does not occur
and for resnet we currently covered this
law if we cheat each block as a single
layer
okay I don't have too much time but uh
let me jump to things to a large
language model the theme of this
Workshop is a large language model uh so
we have done experiments with birds we
first ever we don't see such a clear
linear decay in language models in
general unfortunately uh this is a
certainly something we can expect when
we before before doing the experiments
because for language model because the
attention mechanism there is a within
layer non-linearity the non-linearity
occurs even within a each layer and also
the other has is a sequence it's not
it's not a single there's a horizontal
relationship and it's not discriminative
so we must need a different measure but
I think this kind of law if there's such
law for language models it will help us
understand the underlying mechanism okay
this is the reference thanks for your
time
[Applause]
foreign
we have time for a question or two
very fascinating
um
a follow-on question if you have you
you've done this in synthetic settings
with synthetic data uh uh unreal a real
data actually for Sim set data if we
generate very synthetic it's not that
complex enough that actually we don't
see it's actually near decay uh only the
the last year will occur on
syntheticator if the synthetic there is
a complex enough similar to the real
real data okay so just yeah I'll ask you
in the break yeah yeah thanks
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and she will tell us about collaborative
development of NLP models
hi everyone so my name is
and I want to talk about collaborative
development of LLC models
so I want to start my talk with this
story that probably everyone has heard
there is this elephant in the dark and
then there are many people who haven't
seen elephant elephant at all and then
they go to the room and then they want
to see what the elephant look like and
then because the room is dark or they
have this like headbands they cannot see
the whole elephant so depending on where
they touch the elephant they think that
that's what the elephant look like so
the person who touched the tail of the
elephant would say that or elephant is a
it look like a rope this is similar what
we do in machine learning we train we
collect some training data we fit a
model and then after that we're like yes
everywhere would look like this then you
probably heard a lot a lot about this
like experience features that happen and
then these interesting errors that
appears for example if you take some
sentiment analysis over the shelf and
then you say for example Marco is a
terrorist it says that it's negative but
if you add like Marco is terrorist with
blonde hair suddenly it make it neutral
because like having blonde hairs it is
like movie reviews usually it's such a
good tick
and then if you bring it back to black
hair again it becomes a negative and
interestingly because my name first day
is Iranian and also has connection to
Islam even if I dye my hair still it's a
negative
so for this talk how are we going to
deal with this like training in the dark
so the first motivation is that yes we
are going we collect some data we learn
somehow how this elephant look like but
for example we have a lot of data from
the body of the elephant so we have like
oh everything kind of look like this and
then what I'm gonna do in this talk is
that how can I enable many experts to
come and interact with the model to tell
me how this model should look like so my
goal is to have like a lot of people
that they know different parts of
elephants they can interact with the
model and then hopefully at the end of
the day I come up with something that's
the model that it's aligned with all
these different people expertise
and if you don't like alignment another
motivation is that this like you
probably have heard about software 2.0
you ship your model and then some error
happens then what are you going to do so
you should find these errors you should
generalize them you cannot just like put
them in the training data and hope for
best you should generalize and fix box
so this is the motivation behind the
stock
and how are we going to handle this
there are two main challenges that we
have the first one is how we should help
these humans to operationalize their
concept and debug
so usually they have some like really
implicit idea for example oh nationality
should be Neutron but how can they make
this explicit and they teach it to a
machine learning model
second we should handle interferences so
like in machine learning usually you
cannot change anything locally if you
change something you're going to change
like many different parts of the model
so let's focus on the first one
operational analyzing a concept
let's consider a very simple example
there is this person who cares about
religion religious should be like by
itself should not have any sentiment and
then we want to make sure that if this
model is aligned with the there is the
problem is that humans are not very
creative so if you give them a model
that hey is this aligned with what you
believe they probably come up with like
a few sentences like hey I'm mostly
neutral I love Muslim positive but they
cannot like cover everything for example
again if you take like something over
the Shelf a sentiment analysis these
things usually like work but if you work
deeper you if you like try deeper you
can find examples that they say so the
concept that the mod the human cares
it's usually like super big they can
check like some part of it but they
might miss another parts
another problem is that these models are
really big so even if you find bugs and
then you put them in the model they just
like memorize it they can memorize it
and they're like they are okay those
ones that you found but they might miss
another things
I think these are the two challenges
that we have and then how are we
addressing this
this Workshop is about llm so we are
going to use elements so what's the
first Insight that we have is that we
can use this llms to help us to explore
this big state space
so how are we going to do this
uh one put a property that is llms have
if you start from like five to seven
sentences on a concept that you care and
then put them as a prompt they can
generate like more than 100 examples
in the concept that you care so if I
start from like
let's say I care about nationality being
neutral if I start from like I'm from
Afghanistan I grew up on I grew up in
Iran she lives in USA and then I give
these three to Elena and then it
generates like 100 it can generate like
100 examples for me I choose one of them
again and then I start exploring and I
start doing this like random work in the
status space and then I every time I can
ask human that if I'm still in their
status space or I'm out
so if I'm out they will tell me if I'm
in I keep doing this like random work
what's the problem is that this status
space is very very big so if I'm going
to do this like random work it takes
like forever for me to find the exam box
great if I have some idea that where the
boxes are so instead of doing random
work I do more of a guided what
so how can I get this idea of like where
the error can appear
so if I know that where the error is in
a set of random work I can do this like
guided work towards like the air
but how can we find these high error
regions
we have this our second Insight is that
although these models are very complex
but if we look at at this like very
local regions then things are easier
like you saw probably in Taylor
expansion you saw many of
interpretability results in machine
learning that if you focus on something
like local neighborhood you can have a
singular model and simpler model means
that you need like less a few examples
to learn that model so we are going to
use this second insight to help us to
find the error reaches
so as a summary we have this problem
that user cannot sample from their own
concept
at first Insight was that we can use
llms to help us to to either random bug
or Guide Network and then our second
Insight was that we can learn a function
in a local region that probably needs
fewer example so our solution is that
let's learn a local function in a local
region and then use this local function
to guide us toward the design limit
so how does this would work you come you
give us like just a few examples from
the concept that you care and then I
learned a very small model about like
your concept after that we have this
Global model that we want to find a box
in it and then we have this local model
that like works well in your concept and
then we use gpt2 to generate to do this
like uh
guided work towards like the
disagreement regions so like whenever it
generates some sentences we chose ones
that are like more close like they have
higher disagreement between local and
Global and then it's fine when you find
some sentences that these two models
disagree and then when it finds that
then we ask human that which one is
correct so either the local model is not
good enough yet so it would improve the
local model or be found an error so we
are going and improve the global model
and then after this we update local and
Global model and then we continue this
PCD Loop until the local model and
Global model converge which we call that
like right now the model is aligned with
what the user wants
so it thinks like as you continue for
example on this um
religious one like that oil Muslim I
pray in Mars you see that after a while
they are completely aligned on single
sentences and then like harder sentences
show up for example let's start talking
about Isis start talking about his world
now so as much as this llms here we are
using gpt3 are like know about the
concept we get like more coverage of the
concept
put everything in one slide so we have
this like llms that are have high speed
they're really good with language
generation we have Global model that has
good speed know about the task but has
like very bad idea about the user
concept we have user that knows about
the user concept but it's fat on
language generation and doesn't have
speed and then what we did is that we
have this like proxy model that has a
higher speed and high user concept so
there would be like a lot of interaction
between Global local and llms and then
whenever there is a disagreement we ask
users so that's why the arrow has it's
thinner
so uh the first part of the talk as I
said was about operationalizing concept
we have these problems that users are
really bad on sampling in their data set
or explaining what they want and our
solution was to use llms or and also use
the fact that local functions are easier
to solve this problem
let's now look at the handling
interference
so there are a lot of work in the
literature that they show if you fix
something you're going to break another
thing like you do adversarial training
your generalization goes down you fix
like some experience feature then like
you see that the accuracy goes down for
other things you can see this in like
fairness literature they call it like
lipstick on a peak they fix something
some other things break so how are we
going to handle this like we fix
something we align but we are how are we
going to die deal with these
interferences
to some give you some intuition that
like about interference is that for
example let's say you have two captions
and then you wanna like classify them
and then here if you have like one or
two examples with like high probability
you would have like a very high accuracy
classifier so I need only like a few
examples and then I classify them very
well however if I like a new user come
with new set of data suddenly it still
start interfering with the previous data
so now I need to sample like these data
that are like very low probability to
sample from them now I need to do a
sample from there
so how are we going to handle this again
remember that like I have proxies for
every local uh user so I can use those
to again focus on disagreements and he
invent this
so
here uh
you can see that I have the
I have like one local concept for these
users and then another local classifier
for this and then all I need to do is to
focus on these disagreements to handle
this problem
so the model right now is just like as
previous one instead of like now one
user we have like different users and
then they can handle interferences
because they have their proxy
so as a summary you have these problems
of operationalization that user cannot
uh
sample and we solve it by relying on
llms and relying on the facts that
um
we can use llms and like this local
functions to help us and for
interference we again use this fact that
we have these local functions that they
can help us to deal with interferences
um so we put like bunch of experiments
but I probably don't have time to go
through them
and yes so
we start with like we usually do
training in the dark we want to do
collaborative development we show how to
do operationalizing concept we go
through handling interferences I showed
some experiments you can see in the
paper that it's working and then there's
a conclusion I really believe that like
it would be great instead of like a
single entity decide that how these
models behave if you have something like
Wikipedia for this like models that how
they should operate would be great thank
you
foreign
[Applause]
all right
foreign
who will tell us about the reservoir
Transformer at infinite Horizon
hello everyone
um thanks for the new introduction
um today I'm going to present the work
together with my computer student of
army kosher so we're going to talk about
uh Reservoir Transformer a new type of
Transformer that can handle arbitrary
along
um so we all know that Transformer right
now has a sensitive ability demonstrated
including in the large language model
however one not well known restriction
of the land language model
um implemented for example where
Transformer is the input lens so so far
the Transformer itself can handle
um 1024 in the previous version in the
earlier version tokens as inputs
um there are a lot of work trying to
increase the input length of Transformer
so that they consider more context
including for example G5 3.5 and gbt4
and so on there's also recent work
called a Limited Format that can handle
500K
still these are all restricted links so
we are claiming that theoretically we
can find something that almost has no
clear restriction on the implements and
I will show you how we do that
before I start I want to talk about why
contacts matters here's a small
story adapted from Chile and the
original always talk about papaya and
established into the apple tree so
rabbits white as line
under a tree full of Apple conveniently
and suddenly the apple fall down and has
the sound for example the sound is Guru
and then
the rabbit thoughts is something strange
so instead of shout is the probably the
monster coming
and then the rabbit-toed monkey and the
monkey told a fox and fox called beer
deer tiger and they all drawings and
they think they're mostly with three
um uh with three eyes
so in this context let's say we want to
do a little question answering
so
when we just know the later part
a short sentences at the end we do not
have enough memory
to read the beginning and only with the
end so for this question what is found
is going to answer the monster is coming
however
if we have access to the whole text
then we know actually the apple is
falling from the tree
so in that case we definitely need long
context
which is very different
now what we learn from this lesson we're
gonna read from the end back to the
beginning
um since context is so important what
changes us to use long context so far
it is because
Transformer
memory and time grow quadratically with
the sequence length therefore the
training is actually very very expensive
then what shall we do
how do we remove the training
but
I'm not even machine learning Workshop
now
okay so I'm not completely remove the
training of course but I'm introducing
something
some kind of architect that doesn't need
training so this is not what I invented
as already previously used in different
fields
and we're introducing this Reservoir
into the Transformer here in the
reasonable layers so inside the new the
neuron in the reservoir layer they have
fixed weights and these are initially
randomized this weights so we do not
have the problem of training this part
and you can consider it that you're
reading reading a lot of things and
those ways are fixed if for example you
can linear or non-linear combine what
you read together in fact in this case
it's only not combined but you don't
need to retrain the the ways you're
relying on the large Corpus to give you
some information there
but you do need to train at the end in a
readout layer
but the readout layer is um just one
layer and usually the two linear breathe
out originally so how about we combine
this with the Transformer that means we
have two parts one is sentence wise
dependency that means a whole document
for example a book I will read with the
reservoir and then within the sentence I
still reach with the Transformer because
there's less than a thousand input
tokens
and if I combine these two I'm going to
have both very long very long memory
which is the last computationally
expensive and also the Transformer
itself that I can can give good
attention score from each of the
words in the sentence
so I have like more precise learning
within the sentence and more rough
learning
across the sentence in the whole
document or longer articles
so this is a basic idea but if you just
pack it in it's not going to work very
well so the first challenge we meet is
the
the linear readout because the the
reason we're output size equals the
Transformer input size output goes to
the Transformer input therefore
the Transformer input size things we say
it cannot be very large
we cannot this restrict the reasonable
output sense and then restricted the
number of neurons we can use in a
reservoir therefore we need to modify
the linear readout with non-linear
readout where we use attention Network
here so usually here is the
the linear readout that we can put into
attention your network and here we
replace it with a cell phone tension in
your network okay so two layers
so this is the first challenge
um the Second Challenge is that when we
have very very long forecasting for
example 70 refers forecasting in child
system there is something called
Butterfly Effect so the prediction
actually become really very very
difficult
um after a certain period of time and
this is very much relying on the initial
condition of the input States
so this sensitivity make it very
difficult for prediction
and therefore we have introduced both
Reservoir to unsample the different
inputs
initialization
so that results become more robust
um okay come back to the experiments
um here is a result on the different
Echo synthetic data set and here we have
the reservoir Transformer this number of
parameters the terminal harmens is very
small and the number the the loss is
also small compared to for example
Transformer thing LTM and so on the rest
of them are here
and uh
for time series forecasting we tested
several one is the website visitors gold
price
and also demand price Bitcoin historical
data set we all got detection from MSE
and also improvement from the other
criterrents
and we also tried uh for example other
like currency exchange rates and several
other coppers and compared with for
example a linear linear de linear and so
on
and also a number of kind of operation
on Transformers so we got also
improvements overall and also the air
quality get Improvement uh
in our prediction
and come back to the language model the
reservoir branch that were adapted
has the lowest complexity this is tested
on the wiki text
and last we also tried on the chapel
together with multimodal features we
also got
increased uh talking durations so this
is the
kind of very much uh kind of goal of the
duration of conversation like 20 minutes
and this is what we achieve now together
with a matching model input
so this result is not a long format over
for these guys but also combined with
some other new methods together
okay so in summary we have introduced a
reservoir Transformer that can handle
very long context which is not expensive
and we are able to fully cast events
that is very far away
and we show some improvements
experimentally on time series tasks and
some NRP tasks
thank you
[Applause]
you have time for some questions
it's interesting I missed something
um for the context
dependence for Transformers there's you
mentioned in terms of training which
you're avoiding but there's also just in
terms of executing like to
we're doing training but we are not
training on the whole data so we're
training I'm part of it
it finds easier so we are training so
let's say we have the whole book as one
sample
okay this is Trend here
I hope it's in here the sentence the
trend here
so we avoid to train the whole book here
so that there's no back prop from the
training of the
only here
uh here is retrained this doesn't go
back this is fixed
here is retrained yeah
yeah any other questions
um I have one question maybe while the
next speaker uh starts to set up uh what
do you think are the limitations of the
reservoir model
[Music]
so
the mutation of the model
um
it depends on your standard
so if I want to have even more
efficiency more high quality results
so far we have just compared to the
Transformer we have improvements on the
efficiency and also on the accuracy
but if we want more efficiency and more
accuracy here
for example in certain tasks
we we need oh for example for example
certain tasks we need adaptation
let's say when we do the bird
this has to be redesigned
we cannot use it directly
and this has to be redesigned for the
word uh application
so this is one of the limitation clearly
it could be other imitation families
great
um thank you
[Applause]
our next speaker is song Mai who will
tell us about Transformers as
statisticians yeah thanks for the
organizer and for the audience today I'm
going to talk about Transformers are
statisticians well two days ago Jacob
also talked about language models are
statisticians but he mostly talked about
from more application perspective for
example he showed that Transformers can
use to generate hypothesis
and today I'm going to more focus on a
theoretical perspective I'm going to
prove that Transformers can perform
income tax learning and income tax
algorithm selection and this is more
like a neural network approximation
Theory kind of perspective
this is a joint work with function at
undergrad student at King University and
you buy my long-term collaborator at
Salesforce research well this project
cannot be done without
these two collaborators and then one
Wang and saming zoom from Salesforce
research
okay so uh Surya and Greg have a
mentioned have talked about in detail
about this income tax learning so that I
don't need to introduce in very detail
again but what income tax learning is
that well suppose we have data set x i y
i for ID following some distribution
and what we can do is just to input this
x i y i contaminations and this x n plus
one as a prompt into the charge ability
or Transformers and then this
transmittee can answer
something that is y n plus one hatch and
hopefully the answer is close to this YN
plus one in this example while apple is
X1 fruit y1 so you can see that there
are some gradient shape and sofa is a
Furniture so Birds well then this
Transformer will answer animal
and Greg and sorry I have shown you some
figures saying that well Transformers
well can perform a linear regression or
Logistics regression at least it has a
similar performance of this uh very good
algorithms
in this talk I would like to show you a
further experiment
okay so suppose we have two meta tasks
one minor task is a regression task
where the beta the parameter is like
normal zero identity Y is a linear
function of X associated with this beta
and we form a data set Z drag which is
this x i y pairs that is generated from
the same beta so for a single data set
is as it Associates to a single beta but
then it will generate a ID data sets so
these are
Transformers
and another class of task is this
causation tasks where beta is normal
zero identity Y is binary and we have
this x i y pairs as a data set or as a
meta data point
and we train three Transformers
so we train a Transformer TF rack using
a bunch of regression they have a
regression data sets this data size are
ID but for a single data set they are
composed of this x by y pairs that are
well ID conditional on this beta
for different tasks the beta are
different
and between another Transformer TF CLS
using this coefficient assets
between a third Transformer using the
mixture data sets so half of the data
points are from this regression assets
half of the data set half half of this
metadata points are from this Cartagena
and as we expect well the first
Transformer will have similar
performance as linear regression as
shown by the figure of Surya and the
drag
has similar performance as Logistics
regression and the question is what
about the performance of the third
Transformer
so here this is the experimental result
so the left-hand side this is the test
performance of these three Transformers
on regression task right hand side this
is the performance on calcification task
as you can see this blue of this like TF
right this orange curve match the
performance of linear regression as
expected by the pfcls is sub-optimal but
TF algorithm selection while this is the
third Transformer match the performance
of PF rack
the same as linear regression
on the right hand side is TF CLS match
the performance of logistic regression
as expected TF regression is sub-optimal
but TF algorithm selection match the
performance of
matchday performance of logistic
regression
so while this is surprising because well
we didn't tell this TF algorithm
selection which task
uh this is so we just input a bunch of x
i y pairs this y may be real or maybe
binary but we don't have this
Transformer well which algorithm you
should perform but then this Transformer
can select a proper algorithm
of any task
okay so while this is why I only say
that while these Transformers can
perform some data analysis algorithm
selection like a statistician
so today this talk I will explain why
Transformers can perform two things
first basic income tax learning
algorithm second income tax algorithm
selection
[Music]
so this is a theory talk so to
answer the question why Transformers can
perform income income tax organization
when you look into the inner structure
of the Transformer
so first let's talk about the input
output format of our Construction
so
the input is a matrix H which is a
well each token well is x i y pairs so
the first token is x i x one y1 plus
token x n plus one but here this y place
we left a to be zero well this is the
place that is reserved for the output
and then here we insert some zeros to be
used as scratch patch and this scratch
Pad is very important as we will see
later
a lot of most computations will happen
at this stretch patch
so notice that this
input format is a little bit different
from
cracks or serious talk in their formats
while the input token is X 0 0 y but
here the input format although it's
different but you can very simply
translate translate their input format
to this format so this is without loss
of generality
we hope to construct a Transformer
well a Transformer is a sequence to
sequence function to the output of the
Transformer is uh still a matrix and we
hope that this zero place will be this y
hyphen plus one which is uh well suppose
that asset is a generalized linear model
we hope that this y height and plus one
will fit this generalized linear model
and output something that is close to YN
plus one
and we argue that Transformer can
accomplish this task by performing
approximate gradient descent on some
hypothetical empirical risk
so suppose this is well this is
empirical risk of this regression of
this logic of generalized linear model
tasks and the gradient descent has this
formats
okay so we want to show that this
Transformer can well implement this
algorithm in context well it is like
architecture
so what is architecture of a transformer
a Transformer is a iterative
optimization of the four layers and
attention layers
so the feed forward layers is not very
important it's just a two layer neural
network of each token with a residual
connection structure
and what is important is is attention
layer well here this is a mathematical
formulation of a patient layer each
token each eye is updated by this qkv
interactions so this is the inner
product of Q
query key and then pass through a
naninarity and then times the value
Matrix average over tokens and some over
the head number some over the heads
so one cabin here is that well in our
theoretical construction we made one
modification which is that well this
Sigma we take a to b a value function
instead of a soft Max function and this
is sort of important to obtain some
quantitative error control in our
Construction
okay so well we're going to show that
this Transformer can Implement gradient
descent
and let's compare what's the
architecture what's the formulation of
attention layer and gradient algorithm
so you can see that an attention layer
is just updating this token by this qkv
interaction
and if you write downgrading it's an
algorithm this is like the either this
parameter W is updated by this xwy
interaction and you can see that well
there are many similarities among these
uh in this expression
well it turns out that well suppose you
just construct this
qkv matrices
and then this attention layer and green
instant
formulation are exactly the same so
for uh we can just take this H to be x y
w where this zero place was the scratch
pad and here we store each we store the
weight update of this gradient descent
and then buy some construction of the
qkv we can show that well these two
expressions will match
so that means a single attention layer
can Implement One Step during the sense
so you you concatenate these attention
layers it can Implement L steps of green
sense using L layers of tensions
what about these before layers we can
show that the speed borders are good at
implementing this proximal function so
that means this Transformer architecture
can Implement proximal green descent
which can be used to solve this uh
vessel problem
okay so theoretically we can show that
well there is a Transformer with
controlled in value Dimension number of
layers number of attention heads with
four layers and Norm of parameters such
that these Transformers can Implement
Bridge regression Logistics regression
and so
and these algorithms can achieve Minimax
optimal
error on a certain data distribution
standard data distribution
and additionally well we can find this
Transformer that implement this
algorithm is comparable error
efficiently by just pre-training these
Transformers minimizing well this is
just a Super Wise might have learning
kind of thing just minimizing some
empirical risk and you get some
generalization error control where this
uh thing on top is polynomial in
associate parameters
okay so here this is our the rightful
result upon like how Transformers can
Implement individual basic income tax
learning algorithm
and we want to also show that
Transformer can perform algorithm
selection like this or you can Implement
regression on regression tasks and the
classification on classes
so how can Transformer implement this
well we propose two mechanisms mechanism
one post HCL validation
well this Transformer can run K
algorithms in parallel and select
algorithm with small validation error
so to achieve this it just you just need
to
um we just need one additional layer of
attention layer and just a
okay so maybe like three additional
layers of transformers at the end and do
this string validation test
second mechanism is pre-sl testing and
it can form a hypothesis to select
algorithm
okay so for example if we want a
Transformer to implement this regression
versus classification problem first the
Transformer can just perform a binary
test at least wise if these wise our
regression are just real numbers well
the Transformer then will implement this
regression algorithm if these y's are
binary then Transformers and in
communities classifications
so this is a construction result and and
the arrow can be controlled
quantitatively
and there is another mechanism called
post HCL validation so basically it can
perform just a training validation
splitting and
uh
perform two different algorithms on this
tuning data set and select algorithm by
looking at the test error evaluate on
these validation assets
so in summary we proved that
Transformers can efficiently Implement
simple SCI algorithms using the greedy
descent mechanism and efficient
Implement algorithm selection similar to
as a physician and sex Transformers can
be pre-trained statistically efficiently
yeah do you summarize my talk
thank you
thank you for the great talk we have
time for a question or two
uh for for the gradient descent on the
data I think in earlier today's talk
there's a double distance like phenomena
it's more like solve the these square
like exactly almost but the gradient
descent I think is depending on the
number of layers right or in this uh
construction
um here well there's no double descent
because we consider a regression test
results and noise yeah yeah I I'm saying
like because in the proof I think uh
from my understanding is each layer is
performing one step of creating this
right but I I think if the layer number
is say 20 even 20 it cannot be
guaranteed to converge to very close to
the optimal uh I feel like because
linear regression the convergence is
especially fast right so 20 layers I
think the error is like already
so I think it's not a problem
I think uh 20 layers already covers too
good I think our our architecture is not
a priority because we need eight layers
okay
thank you again song for the great talk
excuse me
thank you
that clicker doesn't quite quite work
okay maybe we'll click through the
manually
if there's something broken on this or
is there a different way to use it do I
need to like
okay
what
I don't know what that means
slideshow
there we go okay
so
I'm Bob Carpenter I'm coming from the
center for computational math at
Flatiron Institute which is also hosted
by Simon's Foundation or at least paid
for by Simon's Foundation
um and what I want to talk to you about
is taking the standard kind of
reinforcement learning that we're doing
now and softening it a bit and I want to
motivate both I want to tell you both
what that is and what I think we'll get
out of doing that which is I think quite
a lot if we can generalize from other
cases where this has worked very well
right so what are we doing and so far I
know what happened up to gpt3 because
they wrote about it but then I stopped
writing about it so I'm just going to
tell you what they did at that point so
they
massively pre-trained a Transformer on a
ton of data right and then they
retrained it again they retrained the
weights to be helpful harmless and
truthful right at least to the extent
possible the alignment data is
critically based on human feedback that
is specifically what we're doing is
we're taking the output of GPT and we're
saying hey here are two outputs which
one of these are better output a or
output B so the human judgments are
going to be in the form of which one of
these things are better right the
training loss for this as Chris Manning
went over as a kind of Bradley Terry
model right we basically have a reward
model for each one of our outputs and
what we're doing is we're looking at the
difference on a logistic scale between
the rewards for these things right so we
get this loss that basically says we
want the score for a to be a lot higher
than the score for B if the human
annotator said that a was better than b
right so the exact form of this stuff
doesn't really matter so don't get hung
up in the details of the the math here
so what one thing I want to point out
the human feedback is relatively
inexpensive they did this by hiring 40
contractors for upwork they didn't say
for how long they hired them for but
even if they hired them for a year at
fifty thousand dollars a year each
that's still only two million dollars
that seems like a lot of money it's more
than I can go spend on a project but
compared to the 500 million dollars in
Hardware they have the AI researchers
they're paying for it at least half a
million dollars a year all the data
licensing servers this is like chunk
change right this is like in the noise
of the amount of money they're spending
on doing this and one of the main points
of this that I have is that I think
there's a Headroom for a lot more
investment in terms of reinforcement
training right now right if we think
about the scaling results we have all
these scaling results for like how much
data we have how much parameters we have
given the compute I'm gonna I'm going to
conjecture there's a scaling law for how
much data and training we do how much
human feedback we do given dollars and I
think we're probably not putting enough
money into human feedback and not really
doing it in the most optimal possible
way
right so one of the things that they
report in the alignment paper from
openai is that inner annotator
agreements only 73 you give people a
bunch of these things right and this was
their hand selected hand-trained
annotators right when they were done
their agreement on saying that a is
better than b was only about 70 percent
right so the one of the problems here is
that the goals they're asking them to
evaluate helpful harmless and truthful
are at odds with each other right being
helpful and providing an answer can
sometimes get in the way of truthfulness
or harmfulness depending on what I ask
you to do it so open AI say that they
prioritize being helpful and they
filtered it later for harmfulness and
truthfulness I'm not exactly sure what
that means there's just a note in the
appendix of their paper
um but the traditional approaches to
multi-annotation when you have multiple
annotators right is to either just don't
do it just have your data annotated by a
single person and I have a feeling
that's probably what they did they
probably did a little study to figure
out what the inner Entertainer agreement
did and said yeah 70 that's good enough
let's just go single annotate because
that's kind of more efficient in
training for the annotator time you have
sometimes right you can also take
majority voting which I would say is
probably the most commonly done thing in
machine learning right the other thing
that's very common in machine learning
is to censor non-agreement if you have
some item in the training debt set and
the annotators don't agree on it just
throw it out and don't use it maybe it's
low quality data right I'm going to
argue that all of these are bad
approaches right don't do any of these
things there's better ways to do this
stuff right so let me just motivate this
with a simple example with classifiers
and I guess people have set this up for
me right so I'm just going to lay out a
Bayesian logistic regression here right
it has we have y n as the outcomes X in
our our covariates or our features Alpha
and beta are regression coefficients
we're just going to assume that we have
some normal distribution over the over
the covariates that doesn't really
matter and we're going to throw some
kind of Prior on these again that's not
really part of the point here but the
way to think about this is that the
logit that this is equal to one is just
going to be this linear function of the
predictors that's just what logistic
regression does so the question is how
do we create a gold standard right what
does a gold standard look like well it
quantizes these YNS down to zeros or
ones even though I've got some
probability that y n is equal to 1 here
at the point I create a gold standard
I'm either going to say zero or one
right and I can do that in two
traditional ways if I want to create an
actual something that looks like a gold
standard that has a definite answer are
for every item either I can take my best
guess I can say if the probability that
it's equal to one is greater than a half
set it equal to one this is typically
what machine learning people do this is
really bad don't do that right this is
much better this is what a statistician
would do instead of saying set it equal
to one if the probability is greater
than half sample it right the reason we
want to sample it is we want to
propagate our uncertainty through our
inference processes as much as possible
Right This is saying we're not really
certain which one it is we Peg it up to
the most likely one we're going to
introduce bias into our estimators right
it's much better right you can do this
all under simulation with logistic
regression in like an hour on your
computer especially with gpt's help
right it's very easy to demonstrate this
kind of stuff in simple cases
right so any one of these standards that
we create is a kind of Fool's Gold
Standard right we know we have some kind
of probabilistic output from the system
yet we're pegging a label at one or zero
we're not really that confident in the
one or zero so sampling dominates taking
the best gas as I said before but
oversampling is even better right I can
sample one y according to this
probability but I can sample more and
then I might get multiple things with
different labels and I'm going to get
them roughly weighted according to the
probability that YN is equal to one but
weighted training is really the way to
go if you have access to this and you
can do this this is by far better than
anything else you can do right instead
of saying that my loss is just based on
a zero or one what I'm going to do is
I'm going to set this equal to the
probability that it's going to be one
and then I'm going to provide a weighted
penalty for it being equal to one and a
weighted penalty for it being equal to
zero right I've swapped the reward
ordering here right what does this do
right why are we doing this for task
driven regularization right we think
about regression regressions tend to be
more robust when you regularize them or
reapply some kind of shrinkage like
regularization is going to look like
empirical Bays where we shrink things
through the population average shrinkage
is just going to bring things down to
zero what this is going to do it's going
to say for this particular instance of a
n and BN I'm only 70 sure that a n is
better than BN so what it's going to do
it's going to try to make the classifier
respect that right it's going to try to
make the classifier push the rewards for
those things closer together such that
this
comes out to be close to the probability
that I'm training with if I said 70
chance of this being a zero one that's
what I want to train with and it's going
to push the classifier to make that
answer to not be extreme a lot of
machine learning classifiers are very
poorly calibrated because they push
prediction probabilities to zero and one
one of the reasons is they're not
trained with this kind of
right so what can we do I've only got a
couple more slides here we can create a
model of annotation I've been working on
this this is the problem that drove me
out of natural language processing the
first time when I was at a company doing
this because we kept having to create
data sets and into Bayesian statistics
because I wanted to figure out how to do
this problem correctly a very simple
model of this is David and skeens from
1978 right and what we want to do is
they give us a model of raider accuracy
and bias that's going to let us predict
what's the probability that a n is
greater than BN not given the underlying
coefficients not giving the underlying
predictors but just given the human
feedback
right so I ask a bunch of humans right
they give me I have some probability
that a n is greater than VN now we can
do the same thing again right what I was
giving you before was like the
simulation take on this this is what
we're going to do for real we're going
to have them rape these things we're
going to have them do this but now we
have the same choices we can take this
this is going to be a probability we can
either use this for weighted training or
we can sample or we can take the highest
probability there's a huge gap between
these two things there's a pretty big
gap between these two things in
efficiency right so multiple sampling
winds up
converging to weighted as the sample
size increases but you may need a lot of
samples yeah sorry whose feedback is
being used in the David or the uh the
model above
the 1978 model we're having a bunch of
human Raiders we're giving you know this
we take the people we got on upwork or
wherever and we give them a bunch of
examples and they say yes no whatever
and we take all that human feedback so
is that their accuracy advice is that
the models accuracy and bias
this is going to be estimating what the
probability is based on the human
feedback we can't assume this is the
correct answer but usually it's going to
be a lot closer than assuming 0 or 1 or
taking a majority voting generally these
models are pretty good
so
um the weighted training wounds up Rob
blackwellizing the sampling perfect I'm
almost done which is really nice David
Blackwell was here they just named a
dorm after M for sale
um majority voting which is common
that's equivalent to taking the best
guess with respect to some kind of
degenerate model right so what happens
is this weighted training winds up
regularizing there's a really great
paper in jmlr from 2010 by vikasa radar
and a bunch of other people from Siemens
on image recognition right and what they
showed is it's possible to jointly
estimate both the classifier and the
David scheme model but more importantly
they showed that taking these
probabilities even though it's very easy
to show in theory they actually did this
to a real problem so they could get it
published in an ml Journal rather than
just a stats Journal right and showed
that this actually works right and our
loss lines up looking like this where we
have the differences of the rewards and
it's regularized because what it wants
to do it minimizes this loss that we've
set up at the point where the system
assigns a probability equal to from the
true data equal to what the Raiders said
oh sorry that should have been a PSI
because I changed notation there
I think that's all I've got so I'll
leave it on the references
thank you uh we have time for one
question
so the
um you know in the scheme where
everybody said you should you should uh
change things for act probabilistically
so you don't change the the statistics
uh much or the expectations so um what
if you only wanted to act if the in the
case that that the signal was very large
if you wanted to condition on that would
could you could you then modify your
your the signal the signal is very large
in terms of the signal from the Raider
from where the signal from the predictor
the the David scheme model does that
right what it does is it basically
estimates the Raiders accuracies and
biases and then it adjusts for that if
you have if you have basically a spammy
type Raider right it's basically cancels
out their contribution and and they
don't have any anything so it tries to
extract the most information and there's
a lot more on this so This stuff's all
being rediscovered as well so while I
was here somebody told me that John
duchy at Stanford wrote a paper on this
this is very similar to the other 10
papers that have been written on this
topic it's like I have a feeling people
come into this and don't realize that
like lots of people have worked on this
problem right so this is there's a
little more Theory here but it missed
all the references to the literature in
the last 10 or 15 years but it's another
another paper along these this is a
paper that I wrote with Becky pasino on
word sense that kind of gives you a high
level ma of view of how the David and
scheme models work and the rest are just
things I cited in the paper
okay great thank you
so we'll meet back here at four for the
last uh session for short talk